I am homely dissatisfied with this proof
okay because this proof it the entire
thing is predicated on the fact that you
knew what the answer was before you
started right if we didn't know that
you've got nowhere to go right like
you're back here we started this was the
only if you've written on the page you
like wherewhere address this is this guy
come from then the answer is it comes by
someone else knew the answer ok now i
will say they're still value in that we
look at mathematical induction the whole
principle of mathematical doctor works
on the fact that oh you know you know
what you're going to get before you
start okay but there are things that
mathematical deduction that make that
still an amazing sort of technique even
if you do know what you're supposed to
end up and also secondly we can't
integrate that we can't integrate this
we have the tools we need like someone
did this once upon a time worked out so
we get from this you'll end up with that
and they didn't know what it was before
they started and then in just like blow
each start differentiating things until
oh cool I got it they actually did this
analytical so here comes method to hold
on to your half it's not easy that is
why rather than of you know the question
walking you through with multipliers and
say okay try this they've just gone
straight to this because so much quicker
and so much easier but when we do this
back then do it from scratch as it
worked like so it's going to be I think
we're going to learn something okay so
it's a good with this then when you look
at this on the face of it especially
given the context I've been looking over
this week what's the first thing that
jumps out for you as a strategy you
could try to make this easier to work
with yeah so I want a substitution a
trig substitution of some coloring
because I've got a sum of squares down
here not a difference sine and cos I'm
not gonna be useful to me I want 10 and
SEC right that's what's going to give me
the relationship so I'm going to say let
x equal a 10pm right if x equals 8 n
theta I'm going to need to have the
derivative with respect to theta so I
can change the variable of integration
which of course is what is the
derivative
okay okay but actually I don't even want
that i want the i want to have DX on the
denominator so i'm going to write one
equals a sec squared if you idiot you're
happy with that ok so now i think i'm
pretty much greater when it's indefinite
a case i'm going to go and try my
substitution and this is equal to the
integral of i'm going to substitute x by
one of the top with that guy so i can
change everything a 6 squared theta yes
on my denominator you can see I've got a
swim fuss what a squared hansford yeah
that's good and there's my deity
promptly kids or so as soon as I've read
the dough ok so far so good you can see
I could do some pretty impressive
canceling here right what am I going to
get I've got my egg sacs we're on the
new moon off down here what can I do i
glue two things right I can take out the
square root of a squared which of course
is just okay and then this is one plus
tan square that gets left behind ok so
it's the square root of six square
okay so you can see a is canceled that's
good so now what do I do with this
because we know we can't just simply
turn this into the one of the cases
there's what's why am I going to deal
with this with this absolutely yeah okay
so I need to come back to the
restrictions that were in place okay so
when you have a look at this I want what
do I want I want I x squared I want the
restriction on that to be well what
would you can go look at it carefully
what restriction exists on X here there
isn't one there isn't one okay so
therefore when I have a look at this I
need to be able to do with all my values
but that's okay because have a look at
all users for our substitutions remember
we did this before this guy if you go
between say for instance I mean it's
positive note so I could go from nought
to PI on tooth but because of this guy
you know what you're just going to go
all the way I'm just going to go I don't
write you want any value that you like
that's okay ten will get it for you
right cuz kept em just goes all the way
you get anywhere you want and the reason
why I do this is because what is what is
SEC SEC is one over cause whatever
caused this is what clothes looks like
between my span to impart to so
therefore its reciprocal is going to
look like this it never gets there right
sorry goes it goes through their gods as
a chance so therefore within this to me
this guy always positive right does that
make sense so therefore I'm going to say
this is sec square theater on sec kavita
and the reason is because all this time
so if it was a bit scarier first
reliably no restrictions I need some
restrictions but when you think back to
what these are it's like yeah I can
restrict that I still get all the values
that I want so this can be restricted
even when this is not it's kind of cool
so that's why I've got the positive case
cancel cancel so I'm enough of this okay
now this seems like progress seems like
progress it is progress but it's
problematic progress right because what
do you do with this this is not a
standard form right what could we do yet
you multiply talking about in my sec
yeah plus standing okay now again what I
can do is if I know it I can see there's
actually some reverse chain rule that I
could you see that's going to get me to
my log but you can only do that if you
know it but if you know and so even
though again that's a part and it will
be quicker it'll get this out in three
or four lines I don't want to go to in
that direction because get it it's
assuming a lot it's assuming I already
know what the integral of this basically
use which I think from memory is log of
Seck theta sin theta okay so therefore
how we're gonna get this okay what if we
learn over the past little while for
dearly weird integrals that are this is
a rational function it's actually one
over cause what could you do with this
thing what techniques do you have
one last hand square okay so you want to
try and use some form of the Pythagorean
me yeah it could work okay except I
don't have like I mean that's going to
send me back for this right like do you
see that's the square root of sex square
that's that bad thing that's where we
actually came from so I'm not gonna
luckily use that and the reason why I
know not to go back in that direction is
because i just used to so it's a little
bit like substituting in simultaneous
equations substituting equation back
into itself so it's like ah cool one
equals one yay for me okay so i can't
reuse it I can't reason